at the front end I got to tell you I'm a
huge fan of the wire I think it's one of
the greatest not just television shows
but pieces of art in the last couple of
decades the wire is a special shell few
television shows inspire a stack of
books about its creation and themes even
fewer inspire a collection of college
courses examining those same things and
only one has inspired the sitting
president of the United States to invite
the show's creator to the White House
for a conversation what is it about this
show that makes it so special in this
video part 1 of my series about the wire
I'll be exploring why the wire is
brilliant without spoiling the plot so
even if you haven't seen the show yet
you can learn about what makes it so
great this video is brought to you by a
towers visit a towers calm to find great
video essays curated by topic
genre and director
[Laughter]
the wire is not a cop show yes a series
of police wiretap investigations is the
spine around which the show is
constructed but the wire starts out at
the very least as a subversion of the
standard cop show where in most police
dramas the moment of chasing and
arresting the suspect is the dramatic
climax these are often the very moments
the wire skips over again down but the
wire is much more than just a subversion
of the classic police drama season 1
establishes a failing corrupt
institution the Baltimore Police
Department you send me a message on this
and the message is don't dig in don't
get fence put a quick charge on this
Barksdale and then get out he sends me
good police and might get it into my
head to do good police work and a band
of rebels within its ranks that are
fighting desperately to eke out any
semblance of what they call good police
work
you're not gonna get Avon Barksdale or
stringer Bell or anyone else above the
street not on Street rips you don't know
that these guys are good they're deep
they're organized they got everyone in
the terraces running scared but what our
detectives are up against is not a
clear-cut set of bad guys just a little
man but a rival institution a Baltimore
drug gang made up of real humans with
their own human motivations an
institution complete with its own set of
rebels hoping to swim against their
system yeah but the game ain't got to be
played like that yo each of the
following seasons adds another layer to
the city examining institutions above
and below the two featured in season one
they used to make steel in Oh season two
adds to decaying port economy and the
labor unions season three adds the
political realm season for the school
system and season five journalism if all
this sounds a little bit dry and
academic box deals name morning friends
mostly relatives
my privacy it certainly is when placed
beside your average episode of Hawaii
five-o listen once you keep pressure on
this okay until the image gets you do
not let up on this in 30 minutes gets
you understand me okay all right all
right the whiner doesn't try to grab and
keep your attention it requires it but
if you give it your attention it will
reward you but it's also entertaining
the show tells this story of a city and
its institutions not through dry
exposition about those institutions but
through the individual stories of an
incredible cast of engaging characters
within those institutions fantastically
acted and brilliantly written by a team
dedicated to realistically portraying
the city of Baltimore we're building
something here detective we're building
it from scratch oh the pieces the wire
reaches a bar for quality of writing
reached by few television shows write
what you know is a basic directive
commonly issued to writers and few TV
writers have exemplified this idea as
well as show creators David Simon and Ed
Burns David Simon was a reporter for the
Baltimore Sun for 12 years where he
covered crime and the police department
extensively he eventually went on to
write homicide a year on the killing
streets and the corner a year in the
life of an inner-city neighborhood both
of which Simon adapted for television
collectively all this can be seen as
nearly two decades of writing experience
closely focused on the topics that would
largely be covered in the wire while he
was still a journalist David Simon
developed a relationship with Ed Burns
who spent 20 years working as a
Baltimore City police officer before
joining forces with David Simon to write
the corner if Simon had spent 20 years
reporting and writing about the topics
that The Wire examines Ed Burns spent 20
years living them including spending
time as a public schoolteacher in
Baltimore
direct experience on which much of
season four story is based as police
detective and crime journalist turned
television writers these two were
interested in far more than making
another cop show to entertain the masses
they aspired to put a contemporary
American crime novel on the screen and
the writers they brought on to help them
do this came not from the world of
television but from the literary scene
novelist Dennis Lehane George Pelecanos
and Richard price would all become
critical parts of the writing team
authors who didn't have much experience
writing for TV but who were all
well-versed in urban crime fiction and
when Simon and Burns expanded the show
to subjects they didn't feel they knew
as well they brought in people who did
Raphael Alvarez another Baltimore
journalist joined the writing team
bringing his knowledge of the Baltimore
docks for season two
William F Zorzi a political journalist
in Baltimore joined to help write a lot
of the political story that starts in
season three with their experience as
authors and journalists these writers
brought to the show a greater
expectation for the audience
they required a level of attention from
the viewers of the wire not normally
demanded by television shows but a level
of attention a step closer to the level
you might have to apply to reading a
book this expectation of attention
allowed the writers to include many
blink and you'll miss at details here's
an example of the type of quick and
subtle storytelling you'll encounter in
the wire this scene from season two
shows omar doing reconnaissance for a
stick up location while he is he notices
these two ladies are doing the same
thing an attentive viewer will see
what's happening in the scene and
understand
Omar's subtle recognition of what's
going on if you're not paying attention
you could easily miss the entire twenty
five second dialogue free seen this
level of subtlety is used frequently
like this scene from season one which
begins to set up bode as a character who
is more on top of things than his
colleagues when he walks up on a bunch
of other drug dealers sleeping on the
job very quick scenes often won't pay
off until episodes later and there are
callbacks to details often episodes or
seasons apart what about the little
bald-headed baby right in here these are
the pawns we like the little bits on a
chessboard bones
one of the things that makes the wire
storytelling so powerful is that while
characters sometimes do express ideas
directly I wonder what you got to do to
get throat of this police force most of
the important and central seams of the
show are developed through this type of
show don't tell storytelling
for instance season 1 is largely about
establishing the institutional
similarities between the drug dealers
and the police officers but no character
ever comes out and actually talks about
this theme on the show instead the show
relates the two by slowly building up a
collection of parallel scenes like this
scene which shows the police willing to
bend the rules how can you put that down
when Sydnor wasn't on the roof yes he
was no he's not he's with daniels while
a few scenes later we get an example of
a gang member
closely adhering to their own rules
these two simple scenes progress the
plot but more importantly their
juxtaposition shows us how both
institutions have rules for themselves
but that the motivations around
following those rules lead to different
behavior within those institutions it's
an incredibly complex idea that's
communicated in a very simple way and
these types of parallel scenes are also
used to show the similarities between
individuals gang members need a judge to
mediate between their differences
knowing like one of the marriage
counselors charged by tower to tell some
fool you need to bring some flowers on
just like detective McNulty and his wife
is mr. McNulty capable of having a civil
conversation with mrs. McNulty yes your
honor over time this collection of
mirrored scenes accumulates to showcase
the similarities in these different
institutions wasn't worth it and how
individuals behave differently or
similarly within them so on the game
buff in the game yeah it's all in the
game it creates a powerful argument one
that appears to the viewer almost as
self-evident through the experience of
watching the show but it wasn't just the
writing team's experience as writers
that made the show what it is they
utilized the team's experience as actual
teachers police officers and journalists
to create one of the most realistic
fictional shows that's ever been put on
TV a man must have a code
no doubt David Simon and Ed Burns had an
extreme level of commitment to
realistically portraying Baltimore and
the institution's within the city when
they came up against a subject they
didn't know inside out they conducted
extensive research whether you're
talking about the interviews with dozens
of stevedores immigration officials poor
personnel custom inspectors and
steamship agents that were conducted
before writing about the ports in season
two or the extensive interviews an
ongoing relationship with Melvin
Williams a real-life Baltimore drug King
who reformed after a long stint in
prison Simon and burns clearly weren't
willing to write about topics they
hadn't experienced firsthand without
extensive research and the commitment to
realism extended beyond the writing
staff to the cast who often went to
great lengths to accurately portray the
lives their characters represented andre
royo who played bubbles the show's
beloved heroin junkie said we were
inspired by the city of Baltimore by the
people in Baltimore of how these
characters were supposed to live and be
portrayed his portrayal of a junkie was
so refined he was once chased off set by
the show's security who thought he was a
real addict and was once handed drugs on
the street by another addict who mistook
Royo for the real deal while Simon and
burns both insisted that no character is
a direct correlation to a person in real
life almost no character exists on the
wire that doesn't have elements of one
or more real-life people bubbles was
inspired in part by a long-standing
informant of Ed Burns
Avon Barksdale and stringer Bell were
both informed by actual drug dealers
like Melvin Williams Melvin Williams
would actually go on to take a role in
The Wire as the deacon he was just one
among many Baltimore locals who had
roles in the show notably propositioned
Joe who was played by a Baltimore native
Felicia Pearson who plays snoop came
from the life she ended up portraying on
screen not to mention the locals who
filled out the roles as extras Simon and
burns often named characters after
real-life inspiration the actual Jay
Landsman who this character is named
after even acts on the show but despite
auditioning for the part he is named
after
he didn't land the role and ended up
playing lieutenant Melo at Norris who
plays a detective in the show by the
same name was the actual Police
Commissioner of Baltimore for two years
right before the show aired bunk
Moreland Tommy Carcetti and many others
draw inspiration from real-life
counterparts surprisingly even Omar
perhaps the most stylized regular
character on the show is a composite of
six different gunslingers who made their
living sticking up drug dealers in
Baltimore the inclusion of those who
lived and knew the life they portrayed
wasn't just so that things looked
accurate these people also helped keep
the show from straying into the realm of
fantasy Steve Earle who plays bubbles
Narcotics Anonymous sponsor and who has
real-life experience
in na said they were encouraged as a
cast to speak up if something didn't
feel right when a location plays such a
vital role in a story you have to be
sure you're accurately portraying that
place and when you watch the wire you
can be sure what you're seeing is
actually Baltimore the show shot
extensively on location row houses like
these were often cleaned out and
redressed to look the same but with fake
dog poop needles and broken drug vials
instead of the real thing and those from
Baltimore who worked on the show were
often struck by how real the portrayal
of the city was Lara schwegmann
script supervisor on the show said about
the opening scene I see this when I
Drive around in Baltimore it was sad but
it was at the same time amazing how real
it felt and how real it looked Fredo
star who plays a drug dealer named Byrd
relates this is very real out here when
I got thrown on the floor and one of the
scenes glass was by my face it was like
hold up let's shoot the glass it was
real in a scene like this one where
street names come into play the names
and locations used are accurate take up
a position on federal west of mouthful
I'm coming up from the south
frequent episode director and producer
Joe chapell recalls when they would
write something and it was on the corner
whatever the street corner was we would
shoot on that corner the commitment to
realism extends into the show's style
itself except in a few select cases all
the music in the show comes from a
source within the world but any hole
left by score is filled by expertly used
sound design which helps to reinforce
the emotion of the story and allows the
city to be a non-stop audible presence
in the show use of diegetic music in the
show is often brilliant like this
chasing where the music playing in
Herc's car and how it cuts in and out is
used for comedic effect
[Music]
lost him rear Stricker 800 block the
show's cinematography exemplifies the
same ethos committed heavily to a
naturalistic approach without resorting
to a documentary-style ization the
visuals manage to be striking and
beautiful but always serve the locations
and the characters and rarely calls
attention to itself like the sound
design it's often expertly used
sometimes even for comedic effect
the game is rigged but you cannot lose
if you do not play the wire story is
undeniably political but the way it goes
about telling that story through its
commitment to realism and by portraying
a portrait of its themes and of the
institution's through a collection of
individual stories keeps it from being
propagandistic the show rarely
prescribes a solution what's this I'm
not sure but whatever it is it can't be
allowed it seeks to mostly illustrate
the problems very real ones problems
that continue to go unresolved to this
day in Baltimore and many American
cities the wire is not a cop show there
isn't a simple good guy bad guy
dichotomy were introduced to bad police
doing the right things for the wrong
reasons and gang members who seem to
have just as much heart as many of those
on the side of the law evil is not
easily routed out we can barely tell who
isn't tainted by malevolence the
audience cannot root for order to be
restored because order itself is corrupt
and those who are willing to buck
against the systems do so out of
desperation because they see no future
for themselves in those systems part two
I'll examine these themes and greater
depths and how the wire uses narrative
structure and other filmmaking
techniques to portray them so if you
enjoyed this video make sure you're
subscribed and keep your eyes open for
part two
this video is sponsored by 8 hours if
you want to learn about a specific
aspect of filmmaking genre or director
eight hours lets you easily find
high-quality video essays on those
topics from creators like me it doesn't
cost anything click the link in the
description or head to eight hours comm
right now to find great video essays
it's an invaluable tool for anyone who's
a fan of the medium or a filmmaking this
is the type of thing video essays really
need so go check it out go to eight
hours calm and follow eight hours on
Twitter to stay up-to-date on great
video essays thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this video
if you want you can go to
patreon.com/scishow and creation of this
type of content I really appreciate all
my patrons and I'll talk to you again
next time